apple's m1 ipad pro has been out for
over a month and we've already reviewed
both the 11
and 12.9 inch models with the conclusion
that the m1 is the best ipad ever made
in terms of the hardware
but the software is extremely limiting
at least for now
so with that said it's time to look at
everything from a completely different
perspective
because we just got some pretty exciting
leaks and rumors
for the next ipad pro coming in 2022
so the big question we're gonna have to
answer in this video is this
should you wait for the 2022 ipad pro
redesign
or just buy the m1 ipad pro right now
and enjoy it for all of those months
that you would have otherwise ended up
waiting
so without further ado let's get right
into it first up next year's ipad pros
are expected to come in the same exact
11 inch and 12.9 inch sizes
as we currently have which i think makes
sense because the 11 inch
is perfect for portability and the 12.9
inch is right on the verge of being a
bit too large
but the main issue with the current 11
inch model is that it doesn't get the
option for the mini led display
and that's why so many people this year
bought the 12.9 inch ipad pro
including us since we had to review and
test out
that new mini led display but thankfully
we're expecting that new display
to come down to next year's 11 inch ipad
pro model
so that's going to be very exciting for
those who don't want a massive ipad
now moving on to a brand new report from
bloomberg's mark german
who is basically the most reliable apple
leaker out there
the ipad pro is getting a totally new
design next year
with the main difference being a
completely glass back
instead of aluminum just like we have on
the current iphones
and personally i think the glass is
going to look and feel
super premium likely coming with the
same matte texture
that the iphone 12 pro currently has
which i love
and if you're wondering why it's coming
with a glass back that's because apple
is planning to add
wireless charging to the ipad pro which
is going to free up the main thunderbolt
port
so you can use it for connecting
displays storage drives or anything else
and apparently apple is experimenting
with adding reverse
wireless charging to that new ipad pro
at the same time
essentially allowing you to charge your
iphone or earpods
by placing them on the back of the ipad
pro but what makes all of this even more
interesting is that according to mark
german
apple is testing a similar mag safe
charging system
for the ipad pro yes you heard that
right
mac save just like we have on the iphone
12
which is what made me finally start
using wireless charging
especially in the car with this awesome
car mount that i love
and bringing mac safe to the ipad pro
makes perfect sense
because you'll be able to use the same
charging puck for both your iphone
and your ipad making it very convenient
for apple users
on top of that having mac safe on the
ipad is going to enable cool features
like having unique stands that attach
with just
the magsafe system instead of having a
huge plate or
case allowing you to easily rotate the
ipad pro into portrait or landscape mode
but the even bigger deal is that a mac
safe stand will be able to wirelessly
charge the ipad pro
at the same time which is basically the
dream setup
for people who want to use it at home
like people already do with accessories
like the very expensive
kensington studio dock now the only
problem with wireless charging is that
the current version of max safe
isn't very fast at all as you can see in
one of our iphone 12 charging speed
comparisons
where 20 watt max save charging took a
full
hour longer compared to 20 watt wire
charging
but it's even worse for ipads because
they take much longer to charge
due to the larger battery capacities so
apple
will essentially have to upgrade max
safe to make it
faster which is also going to benefit
the iphone now on top of
all of that we're expecting a new magic
keyboard case
to launch alongside the 2022 ipad pros
and that's based on a patent that apple
applied for
showing a new magic keyboard with a
double hinge
which will allow it to sit higher or
fold flat down
onto a table which are things that the
current model can't do at all
and going even further that new magic
keyboard case is going to feature a new
apple pencil holder
within the hinge which will actually
wirelessly charge it
at the same time and if you're wondering
how that's going to be possible
we actually had rumors of a third
generation apple pencil coming
which is going to be shorter than the
current one making it perfect for the
rumored ipad mini 6
and it's going to make it easier to fit
into the new magic keyboards hinge
now in my opinion i think there's a good
chance that apple will build
maxsafe into the magic keyboard itself
to allow for pass-through charging
meaning that
apple will be able to get rid of that
usb-c port built into the current magic
keyboard's hinge
which charges the ipad pro through the
smart connector
which also handles data transfer like
track pad and keyboard
inputs as well as sending ambient light
sensor data
to enable the automatic keyboard
backlighting
the only issue with the smart connector
right now is that the charging speed
using the usb c
port in the hinge is severely limited
compared to charging with the dedicated
thunderbolt port
only accepting 20 watts of power instead
of around 32.6
watts so what apple can do is completely
get rid of the smart connector
altogether
which would make total sense if they're
giving it a glass back
and all of that data and charging would
happen through a
brand new second generation mac safe
wireless charging system
that will also be able to handle data
transfer for all of those keyboard
features
and if you think about it going this
route makes absolutely the most sense
if apple wants to go completely portless
on the iphone
since a new second gen max safe that
handles data transfer
will be required to be able to back up
your iphone
or use recovery software on a mac so the
nice thing about
that new magic keyboard case is that
you'll be able to attach
the max safe charging puck right on the
back of the magic keyboard
so it'll line up perfectly and be able
to pass through charge the ipad pro
allowing you to use the thunderbolt port
for high speed
data transfers and speaking of that new
thunderbolt port the only issue with it
is that it's being limited by the
internal ssds
read and write transfer speeds so
hopefully apple is going to upgrade the
ssds next year
but in terms of performance the 2022
ipad pro
is almost surely getting the future m2
chip
with the same 8 core cpu and 8 core gpu
layout
because the current m1 chip is already
hitting the thermal limits
of the very thin ipad pro's chassis so
in reality the next ipad pro isn't going
to be that much faster than this one
already
is now with all of that said let's go
back and answer the original question
on whether you should be waiting for the
new ipad pro next year
or if you should just buy one right now
and wait for the software to improve
well first of all looking at apple's
timeline for ipad pro releases
there's a good chance that the new model
isn't coming until the fall
of 2022 which is almost a year and a
half from now
basically a very long time to wait on
top of that
the current m1 ipad pro is already close
to being
feature complete or peak ipad if you
think about it it's already got the
thunderbolt port which is the best port
you can get
it's already got the m1 chip which is so
powerful that it's hitting thermal
limits
it's already got a sweet design with the
best stylus the apple pencil
out there it's got face id it's got all
the cameras you would ever need and
lidar
including the new ultra wide selfie
camera
it's got incredible speakers and the
12.9 inch model already has
a killer mini led display so the
question for you is if you think that
new glass back and wireless charging
is going to be worth waiting for as well
as the mini led display coming to the 11
model and the new magic keyboard case
which is likely going to be even more
expensive
especially if you need the new apple
pencil 3
to take advantage of the built-in hinge
charging system as well
as the max safe charging puck that you
need to buy to take advantage of the
wireless charging
so based on all of that i think it would
be wise to just buy the m1 ipad pro
right now
and enjoy it instead of waiting for
something that
might not be that big of an improvement
especially since you're gonna have to
spend a lot of money
for a full setup if you totally disagree
with my thoughts and conclusions go
ahead and comment your thoughts down
below
but if you enjoyed this video definitely
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one
definitely watch one of those two videos
right there thank you for watching and
we'll see you in the next video